was wir feststellen müssen glaube ich
dass wir eine neue Krise haben ihren
erst Corona jetzt haben wir die
Energiekrise wir haben eine neue
Regierung ist die groko jetzt die Ampel
aber die Verhaltensmuster seit Corona
offenbar doch die gleichen sind denn wir
erinnern uns alle an dass fast schon
übergriffige oder das übergriffige muss
man sagen des Staates wieder Staat in
der corona-pandemie anfing bis ins
kleinste Detail das Leben der Bürger zu
bestimmen es ist ebenso sagt Karl
Lauterbach es ist ebenso meine Damen und
Herren liebe Zuschauer das hat
spaltungspotenzial absolut also diese
Übergriffigkeit diese Hochnäsigkeit
diese Doppelmoral und diese Arroganz von
Karl Lauterbach in diesem Fall die sorgt
dafür dass das Land gespalten wird und
genau diese auch Maßnahmen sind es dass
die Menschen auf die Straße gehen werden
die Ampel tut also das Gegenteil von dem
was sie eigentlich will sie führt nicht
zusammen sondern sie spaltet hier wird
der Staat übergriffig und macht Dinge
die ihm nicht zus